we know all about the lorax the grinch
and horton
but now let's find out how dr seuss made
his fortune
[Music]
the late dr seuss is number two on
forbes highest paid dead celebrities
list
earning more than 33 million dollars
over the past year
he was born theodore soy geisel but went
by ted for most of his life
when ted was a kid he loved going to the
zoo with his dad
he'd carry around a sketch pad and draw
the animals many of which
may have become the inspiration for
future characters
ted kept up with his passion in college
sketching cartoons and writing under the
pseudonym
soos his dad wanted him to become a
doctor but that
wasn't in the cards so in traditional
ted humor
he added the title facetiously he also
decided to just go along with the way
people had wrongly been pronouncing his
last name his whole life
so dr soice was now dr seuss and he was
ready to take on the world
but he hit a speed bump his first
children's manuscript was rejected by
publishers 27 times
until his first book was finally
published in 1937.
over the next few decades he created
classics like the cat in the hat
green eggs and ham how the grinch stole
christmas the lorax
and oh the places you'll go both kids
and adults gravitated towards the unique
characters and magical worlds he created
and he went on to win a pulitzer prize
three caldecott honors
and even received seven honorary
doctorate degrees
he released more than 60 books until he
passed away at the age of 87.
after his death his wife audrey founded
zeus enterprises which expanded outside
the world of traditional publishing
she spearheaded projects like the grinch
which went on to become the world's
second highest grossing christmas film
seussical the cat in the hat and horton
hears a who
audrey passed away in 2018 but the
company's mission continues
seuss enterprises is adapting the
written world creating a multimedia
universe of sorts
first up on the menu netflix's green
eggs and ham
the most expensive animated series ever
made
thankfully it was a success hitting
number one on the netflix charts during
its debut week with the second season in
the works
and for the next course there's a three
movie deal with warner brothers
two films based on the cat and the hat
as well as the third film based on oh
the places you'll go
but fear not dear viewers though the
doctor is gone the magic he created will
live on
and on
you